we're developing a software bull
roboticle that could go in a person's
hand that would be useful for patients
who have lost the ability to grasp
objects these could be patients with
muscular dystrophy ALS incomplete spinal
cord injury we're trying to create a
solution that will let them to be able
to perform activities of daily living
using soft robotics you can make a
device that's a lot lighter and that is
a lot easier to align and to put on to a
person's hand and ultimately we believe
will also be more comfortable for the
user for people with we can't stripe a
simple task or everyday challenges their
hands most of the times are very weak
and their fingers are very flossy I'm
not you know I'm not physically active
at all I can't fix things I can't hang
pictures I you know I mean just every
way possible I can't write I drop my
glasses I drop cups and dishes and food
items and it would just be wonderful to
feel like I could just control my
environment a little better my life a
little better when we have patients that
we see we're trying to understand what
is the size of their hand and one of the
motions that they're trying to perform
and then when we build the soft robotics
actuators we can actually mechanically
program them by tailoring the material
properties so that those actuators
actually produce the desired motion that
we want that is also similar to what the
motion of the fingers would be trying to
do if a person was healthy I wouldn't
attempt to pick these up with my right
hand because it's just not strong enough
to reliably pick anything up like that
with the glove it's like having a
handbag it works the soft actuators on
this device acts as a extra muscle layer
writing on the back of the finger and
provides the extra force finger needs to
close around an object
it feels really nice things like this
round are very difficult for me to do
one-handed if at all my hand doesn't
work very well
fully extended so it's wonderful to be
able to pick this up we can design an
actuator to mots entirely the anatomy
all that the users finger and we can
specify whether the knuckles are where
the bending parts were the extending
parts and even for the thumb when we
have a much more complex motion where
the twisting of the actuator will take
place I think it's wonderful it's really
comfortable if anything it feels good to
have it on it feels nice to have my
fingers extended but most of all it's
the function to have strength in my hand
again it's just wonderful to be able to
firmly grasp something and not feel like
I'm going to drop it going forward I
think it's going to be how do we make
this device smaller how do we make an
even lighter and how do we have it like
the user to control it very intuitive
Lee so that as they're trying to perform
tasks the device is just working
synergistically within